what's happening man it's that East
Oakland rule Boy [ __ ] Delo make sure
you tap into my [ __ ] bootleg cab
podcast man
yo bootle cat podcast special guest my
guy he's home yes I am Dilo welcome man
welcome man how long were you uh sitting
down this last time uh two two years in
a little change and nothing too crazy
it's gonna be the final time right
definitely okay I'll deal with that [ __ ]
good good to hear man yo um it's crazy
because I've been going to the Bay a lot
lately and you always like I feel like
you're kind of like one of the um
like unsung heroes of your area like you
know what I'm saying in terms of like
just like you got legendary records bro
you got like a lot of your peers
respects like
do you feel like um getting like
incarcerated
did it was it kind of like a necessary
evil for you to kind of like really get
back focused the right way on the music
[ __ ]
uh yeah kind of but
I mean when you go to when you go to pre
when you go to jail or whatever and you
rap
jail always kind of been good for
rappers right with getting released yeah
when boozy got out he was getting stupid
back so it's like when I was in there I
was just planning for my release the
whole time you remember planning for
everything that I'm gonna do when I get
out like how I'm gonna better myself
with my music and just life period you
feel me and just be on some some grown
[ __ ] for real something a little a
different Delo but the same deal you
feel me when you got locked up was it
during the pandemic or before it was
during the pandemic well I caught the
case like 2019 so I was out on Bill and
then I went down during the pandemic so
I I caught like the first little half
you got the first part of it I caught
the worst part of it yeah when it was
like you couldn't leave the house
especially in the bank shut down and
there wasn't no nothing in there so you
get out and San Francisco and like just
the Bay Area in general Oakland
Everything Has Changed drastically
almost like it feels like the pandemic
kind of like might have permanently
damaged like the city Loki like or the
area like it definitely did that [ __ ]
looked like
it ain't the same from when I left for
sure 100 like um you know some of the
it's crazy the craziest [ __ ] is like I
think in the city of San Francisco you
could still
and shoplift up to a thousand dollars
and they can't arrest you have you heard
about this what
what the hell so like if if it's been
going viral like people will just go
into like now if you like if you're in
the city you'll see like the CVS's and
the Walgreens and [ __ ] too yeah because
everybody was just going in and just
stealing like 900 worth of [ __ ] and just
leaving and there's nothing they could
do about it yeah I think it was after
like a certain amount it's like
that's when it becomes big like it's
it's petty theft before then yeah like
they can't take you to jail they
probably write you a ticket or something
but they can't take you to jail they
can't arrest you that's crazy that's how
people using that like why would I go
pay for some [ __ ] exactly if y'all if
I'm not gonna go to jail yeah I was just
with a you know what I'ma show my guy
John Costa now shout out to John Costa
you remember John me and John were in
the bay last week and he shoplifted I
said bro what are you doing he stole the
gum I said I said John you can't add to
the problem what is wrong with you bro
just walked out to go it's just like
damn it's like it's not gonna happen
yeah you're right
um but not definitely um
it's crazy out there man it's just like
with the drug [ __ ] like you know this is
his dad obviously I feel like bipping
has gotten worse than it's ever been the
day I got to Oakland from jail this time
I stopped at cookies did you get [ __ ] I
was in there five minutes the day you
got home oh man the day I got here the
day I got home
cookies to get some weed go in there
come back out the big whips I mean the
whip bits I said the whipped a bit but
yeah my [ __ ] was but I said God I don't
be a bit before that's like my third
time but I was like bro this is how I
get my welcome home that just woke me up
like
was there anything in the car they
didn't even take nothing it was [ __ ] in
there but they didn't take nothing it
was like they bent my window and got up
out of there or something like yeah I
feel like a lot of people tell me now
they're like yo if you come to the Bay
you have a rental car take everything
out just keep your windows rolled down
man because they're gonna bust your
window even if they don't see none they
just gonna crack the window off really
rolling your windows now just let people
go in and see what your car unlocked
everything just go ahead come on in for
the window yeah cause the wind getting
the window replaced the biggest headache
yeah that's it I said crazy it's insane
man
um what was uh in 2019 what charge did
you get where you had to go sit down for
I had uh
for a weapon I had a gun and a high
speed so yeah you know they play dirty
they they try to uh they gave me four
years for that which they shouldn't have
but you know do you feel like because
it's crazy man because like California
obviously is
resource wise landscape-wise city-wise
culturalized probably one of the best
states but I do feel like it's gotten to
the point where like
they're making it really hard for
[ __ ] to want to stay out here
because like think about like I mean we
just lost pnb Rock yesterday you know
what I'm saying like it's really like
hard to be able to carry a gun out here
like it's hard like they make it you
gotta jump through hoops and then like
even then like
be really you can't really like shoot
nobody yeah even even
self-defense in California is even crazy
it's hairy it's like you can't you could
you could defend yourself and and still
and catch a charge because of the way
you defended yourself they want you to
do it they want you to
leg check a [ __ ] when if this
[ __ ] don't pull out a gun and
you happen to pull your [ __ ] out and
able to you feel me do your thing or
whatever you know shout this [ __ ] five
six times now you going to jail cause
you shouting too many times they saying
you thought about killing him and all
this crazy [ __ ] like this [ __ ] is wild
it's California crazy got lost crazy
yeah other states [ __ ] just riding
around
did my birthday party I don't know nine
years ago 10 years ago 2013 in Phoenix
yeah it was like you Charlemagne glasses
Malone Freddie Gibbs
but lazy you could ride around like free
there's I mean a lot a lot of people
ain't getting robbed the Navy because
they know you might in the club with the
gun on him I promise you yeah walking
around that [ __ ] just good yeah
it's crazy man I want to go back to uh
we were just talking about uh I was just
talking with Russell about uh NoHo and
how it is such an iconic record on the
west coast but it also is a record that
doesn't sound like it was mixed or
mastered it sounds like you got the
studio bounce and just rolled with that
thing that's exactly what I did yeah I
recorded it so okay so you just balance
it out you're like I did everything I
did the beat I recorded it and I did the
I didn't know how to mix or nothing like
that I didn't know what plugins was I
didn't know what none of that was I just
knew how to press record and adjust the
values that of each track you feel me
and and that was that do you remember
like um
that specific record obviously is like a
record that changed your life but do you
remember
like the moment where you were like oh
this is this is a like this this is one
of them ones
like when I first did it I just was like
on some regular like oh yeah this [ __ ]
slap you tell me yeah and once I put
this one my space was cracking so once I
put it on my MySpace and just all the
locals start grabbing it and putting it
on their page not to see other people
put it on there and I'm just like oh
okay they [ __ ] with the song but then
I went to jail and when I got out of
jail I went to jail for a year and when
I got out that's when it was like big as
[ __ ] then it was on YouTube and all that
because that like we didn't really have
no nobody was dropping [ __ ] on YouTube
then it was like all my expression so
once I got out that's when I really knew
like
oh yeah I had a show the first day I got
out of jail the day I got out I went for
I did my first show ever what year was
this like 2012 2011
2007. oh [ __ ] wait when was when did
Noah come out No Hoe came out only on
MySpace
2007. it didn't hit Youtube and all that
[ __ ] until like late 2008 Jesus so it
was just so you got out of jail and you
had you had a show already booked I have
a cell book shout out to DJ Slowpoke he
uh put up on me and and he had a party
he was like man they love your [ __ ] he
like you gotta come you gotta come do
the song wow I went and did the song and
and lightweight froze up then when I
seen how the whole crowd New Year knew
the words and [ __ ] that that's who made
that's how I started started to stomp to
know how cause that that was the first
thing I seen wow as soon as the beat
came on the whole party stomping I'm
like oh that's crazy we gotta stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our folks at my bookie ladies and
gentlemen [ __ ] NFL season is
approaching
favorite time of the year God damn it
it's good times and the Rams versus the
bills is happening kicking off the whole
regular season and there's no way to get
ready for that regular season like
getting ready for that winning season
all right I'm talking about putting some
[ __ ] money in your pocket you
could be a veteran better like me or you
could be a first time better and you
just want to get a little taste of the
action my bookie has got you because
right now they got that double deposit
bonus if you sign up at mybookie.ag
right now go to my bookie it's quick and
easy let's say you put 250 bucks in you
get 500 to gamble with that's right it's
a double deposit bonus but you have to
use the promo code
bootleg
b-o-o-t-l-e-g it's also in the
description of this video you can just
click the link and you're in there so go
to mybookie.com use that double deposit
bonus by using the promo code bootleg
you gotta register today use it and
let's get this NFL season [ __ ]
cracking I'm talking listen I don't even
know the line of the Rams Bills game
games about a week out on some change
away depending on what the [ __ ] you're
watching this but
Bill's money line what are we doing all
right my bookie sign up use that promo
code bootleg right now and get that
double deposit bonus if you put in a
thousand dollars you get two thousand
dollars to gamble with you put a hundred
you get 200. it's that [ __ ] easy my
bookie go run it up let's get back to
the interview
uh who are you a fan of right now uh
because obviously the bay is there's a
lot of dope Young Artists a lot of a lot
of guys who are low-key ogs like Simba
you know Simba's finally getting some
national recognition
um and he's been around a long time but
who are you [ __ ] with right now out
of out of the uh area that uh you feel
like you know could be uh up next to
represent the city properly man um I say
this [ __ ] named a lot to uh young Jr he
from the town he's fired he raw as [ __ ]
uh
of course little Russell
um
I got an artist named Nims he really
turning up Ella heart and I'm really a
fan of him now because he's my artist or
nothing like that but the [ __ ] dope as
[ __ ]
um he's doing a lot of different [ __ ] he
do like reggaeton
he do he do all everything you feel me
but right now I mean Oakland I can't
speak for Oakland right there and it's
not turned up like that that's why you
feel me the guy is back you know what
I'm saying and I'm gonna turn this [ __ ]
back up one time but other than that I
said Junior right now that's the one
yeah he's fired that's that's who I'm a
fan of right now you feel what I'm
saying super dope yeah there's some dope
uh oh shout out chippers too
yeah shout out to like baby gas is
though that's my boy
um stunt of man's dope stun a man's dope
he's one of them records that's gonna be
get played in the bay forever I was I
was seeing that [ __ ] in jail I'm seeing
all the football players doing it and
everything yeah I was like oh yeah he
moving when like where you were locked
up were you able to have the iPad
or like the tablet because I know some
some places you get the tablet now which
kind of makes life a little bit better
yeah they had the tablets and [ __ ] I had
a phone no [ __ ] tablet yeah I had
cell phones you're able to talk about
that now is that you're out of there
okay
if they the ones they're the ones
bringing the [ __ ] in there [ __ ] the CEOs
the CEOs bring the phones in
[ __ ] janky in here they janky
as hell yeah hella janky they get there
at the end of the day yeah how do they
bring them in though
your guess is good of mine yeah they lay
back [ __ ] I don't know almost like it's
like their own phone they bring it in
yeah yeah yeah so is the service like do
you gotta is like one service better
than the other in there like being here
really yeah unless unless you in a
prison where you just way out in the
boonie somewhere right and then you
probably ain't gonna have no receptions
so at night when you go to sleep because
that's obviously Contraband where do you
put the phone oh yeah we had places I
can't say all that right on here but we
was talking [ __ ] was tucked yeah you
ain't getting to it we had tools and
hella [ __ ] like you wasn't getting to
nothing I left I left
still with a phone but if you feel me
wait you brought wait no I didn't I
didn't wait to say you brought the phone
out of the cellar that's great bro I
left it there I was able to parole and
you feel me and I get caught with it and
[ __ ] like that but yeah shout out to you
were you like on Instagram and [ __ ] in
there yeah yeah you were tapped in there
I mean I wasn't posting right I'm in
jail no no cause that would be stupid on
Instagram but you're at least you could
see what's going on in the world I was
watching the whole time yeah what is
your uh go-to spread recipe
oh
my go-to spirit rest me fettuccine
so how would how would someone like give
me the ingredients the same as like oh
we in prison you can buy all the same
[ __ ] you could buy on the screen she
could buy fettuccine you can buy the
real brand of fettuccine
sees anything you think of they got it
in prison anything so when we see people
like doing like these struggle prisons
struggle prism that's that's County Jail
[ __ ] okay okay okay that's when you're
gonna see the noodles crunched up in a
bag you don't make you don't you don't
touch noodles in prison I just saw a
video that went viral where they were
doing like Hibachi in jail oh yeah
they're gonna take his whole bunk you
know the bunks is metal in here take his
whole bunk and scrape everything off of
it and Fry food on that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] is crazy yeah I love some
creative are they still doing a lot of
prison tattoos yeah right now somebody
getting attacked a thousand people get
every day do you have any tattoo you got
in prison no I was scared of that yeah
no I feel you I'd be sketched too yeah
like you know they say you pay for what
you get when it comes to tattoo artists
my luck bad so
they say it's easy for you to get
Hepatitis uh
for prison tattoo and they tell me
that's all I needed to hear oh thought I
was going in there uh going I'm talking
about the first time I went to prison
I'm thinking I'm going there if I go get
tatted up
doctor said oh yeah you know it's it's
one of the easiest ways to catch
hepatitis I said hepatitis to me is AIDS
to me so I'm like well you can't get rid
of it exactly I'm all like if it's
anything you can't get rid of I'm scared
of it [ __ ] herpes HIV hepatitis in
fact if there isn't a cure for it I'm
out for real yeah I'm saying like
definitely yeah it's crazy
um so uh what is next for you in terms
of like you're out I'm sure I mean the
campaign is rolling new music coming
uh I'm just dropping bro I'm just I'm
just dropping I'm just coming with a lot
of content uh keeping the people
entertained you feel me uh uh I'm just
coming with hella new [ __ ] I got bigger
songs bigger records are you still doing
uh just show through Empire yeah yeah
shout out to guys
shout out to that whole that whole Camp
you know I've been on Empire from the
rip from the red I've been with Empire
longer than anybody else on Empire right
now I don't doubt that yeah cause I'm
thinking
when I think of Empire early days I
think of you I think a sage I think it
was John Hart me sizing John Hart yeah
that was it at that point like that's
when get her though and uh red nose and
right and Who Booty we always doing
radio runs together so yeah we was we've
been rocking since then get her though
was one of them ones too for Shelly
shout out to Tiger shout out my [ __ ]
that was like uh that like whole era of
like 98 BPM ratchet songs yeah it's just
tiger somehow made his way on every
single remix
I was just like I was just talking to
Joe Moses I'm like damn tiger was on do
it for the ratchets remix
God damn this [ __ ] was jumping
on every he's like you're gonna play
Rack City and then you're gonna play the
remix of all the songs that I that
aren't mine that I'm on yeah for real
that was a good time man good timing
just west coast clubs yeah I was having
a hell of fun yeah we was especially
coming up this way and I wish people
would make that like I feel like there's
like a lack of that kind of [ __ ] in the
club right now like I don't feel like La
artists or Bayer artists are making like
those records right now yeah they know
Turnt Up
songs right it's like missing low-key
like there's like some [ __ ] like pilos
doing a good job of making [ __ ] that you
know is cool but like I feel like I
don't know man like the Stoneman record
is cool I just mean just hanging on my
ratchet the ratchet [ __ ] like the [ __ ]
that the business you know what I do you
feel me I got something coming right now
that's gonna turn all that up good I
promise you that's good two I got two
big features on it uh y'all see real
soon I'm announcing real soon the song
been done you feel me uh we working on a
video right now and uh this [ __ ]
gonna wake up all the clubs strip clubs
okay that's what's missing yeah and
that's what's crazy is because like
Tiger's been like uh putting out records
that uh have been less than favorable in
my opinion and I'm just like let's not
overthink this tiger put out some [ __ ]
talking about can we get some more of
that YG same shot like YG where's the
[ __ ] ratchet where's the
ratchet [ __ ] just give me one of them
give me one like uh mozzie put a record
out with YG on the hook called put it in
my face that was reminiscent of those
hearts yeah I was like okay this is this
I like this one appreciate y'all
watching but listen our partners at Blue
chew they got you handled fellas and Etc
whatever you are they got it if you got
a dick Bluetooth is for you because they
will make sure your dick performs at all
time levels I mean like LeBron his first
three seasons with the heat type levels
I mean your wife will thank you for it
everybody will thank you for it [ __ ]
even if you just take a blue chew and
jerk your dick it's a it's a stronger
jerk I swear to God stronger [ __ ] jerk
for sure you're gonna be beating your
dick like a stole something so what you
got to do is go to bluetooth.com right
now use the promo code bootleg right now
and you're gonna get your first month
free and this is the great thing about
Bluetooth the same active ingredients as
Viagra and essialis
but uh you don't got to go to the
doctor's office yeah who wants to go
hang out at the doctor's office and be
like hey Doc you got some [ __ ] pills for
me nobody wants to do that no you sign
up at Blue use the promo code bootleg
and you're getting your first month
delivered to your door in discreet
packaging I'm telling you you're gonna
think me later all right if you've
gotten Bluetooth already just DM me tell
me just just DM me no photos just tell
me how you know let me just tell you
it's [ __ ] amazing our producer
Cyrus's daddy 70 took the blue shoe he's
[ __ ] just beating down all the senior
citizen [ __ ] available in Arizona right
now so go to bluetooth.com use that
promo code bootleg or just hit the link
in the description of this video let's
get back to the interview uh you got the
Mac Dre tattoo uh I feel like not a lot
of people understand like kind of the
dynamic of Mac Dre's career would you
say that he wasn't fully appreciated
until he passed away
kinda
but I feel like I feel like he was
appreciated but
a lot it was a lot of people that didn't
know who Dre was until he died so the
[ __ ] that didn't know Dre he
had a crazy fan base well that's what
I'd always heard like that it was more
like the white boys the Berkeley guys
like kind of the nerdy like rap dudes
who were like super tapped in with Mac
Dre you know they were super tough then
it was like when you say that them is
like his fans like those were like his
core of real film or fans you got blacks
and every you feel me right of course of
course of course right probably not as
much but when he passed away I feel like
his influence was really felt yeah man
he had so much music bro he was he has
so much [ __ ] that's my favorite rapper
so I I know everything from the start to
the end like that's your goat that's
that's my goat right there oh God [ __ ]
asked me who my favorite rappers Trey is
number one who's number two
give me the top five
my this my me your personal favorite
person of course uh Dre
the old Little Boosie okay
um
Messy Marv
I don't even think I got a top five
that's three it's a good three the old
Lil Boosie not a fan of the new Lil
Boosie I mean out here
I'll get it wrong new Lil Boosie cool
but I I when I if I'm gonna play some
Lil Boosie you can play old [ __ ] I'm
playing all all little boost in my mind
playing him and Webby all that I just
pulled up here slapping Webbie just now
shout out to Webby man I wish Webby
would do more [ __ ] I feel like he should
do a podcast or something because he's
hilarious whatever he was hard yeah it
was crazy
if I had to go to my homicide pot and
and 40. that's fair Tupac and 40. yeah
yeah
how dope is it to see a guy who's like a
peer of yours uh
you see Berner making the Forbes list or
the Forbes cover not even the Forbes
list he's on the cover of that
[ __ ] yeah that was big I mean
that [ __ ] is insane because you know
burn has been in the trenches as like an
independent rapper in the bay forever I
don't know a burner for so long it
burner when all tour together meet him
JD's I for me to see how he went I
watched his whole everything I watched
him go from start to now it's crazy
Forbes it is truly it's like it's like
crazy man I always say like you know
somehow he doesn't get enough like
respect or or flowers but I'm like this
guy's richer than every rapper everybody
like I don't know
maybe like Jay-Z like but we're like
we're talking about like on some
businessman [ __ ] like burner's richer
than everybody I need to make more money
in a day than what [ __ ] making a month
it's crazy like whatever City you're in
the building is blue and you have to
pull up to get your weed it could be
Detroit it could be wherever you're at
there's a cookies if there's a if wheat
is recreational in Vegas oh yeah it's on
the Strip yeah oh that's crazy
everywhere and it's like a it's like an
attraction it's like oh we gotta we
gotta go to the cookie store oh we come
out to LA we gotta go to the cookie
store It's gotta go to the cookie stuff
and that's not even mentioning like the
clothing line doing like stupid numbers
exactly it's insane man
yeah yeah he did his thing with that
shout out burner man 100
um so all right so new music coming you
got a new single coming with two
features that you can't talk about
all right
who's on the song who's on the phone
give us one of the two
fifty percent of the features
look man
all right I'm gonna say this okay
it's that song is done though so the
other guy from the bay or LA
he from L.A oh
yeah
don't be trying to guess kid okay don't
be trying to guess we know you gonna
guess right and I ain't and I'm alive
and say no that ain't him
g-eazy's on the record yeah my [ __ ]
G-Eazy man great guy easy man he uh as
soon as I came home you feel me tapped
in and got me to come to the club I saw
that man nice so I brought me out that
was a good feeling that's my [ __ ] right
there good times man well let's get
genuine dude for solely we have to keep
you out oh no I'm Gonna Keep Me Out yeah
oh I ain't going back is it hard like
because I have cousins that have been
like in and out of prison their whole
lives and I feel like you get out of
jail
you get out of prison rather whatever it
is and it's almost like hard to shake
like is it the environment is it the
friend group is it the mentality what do
you think it is that like most people go
through when it comes to like ending up
back in the same place not even yourself
specifically I mean you obviously know a
lot of people who have
um well you just gotta change yo your
direction like you got to change our
Direction the people you're around or
the things that you're doing like
because I could still be around the same
[ __ ] who's out here committing crimes
and [ __ ] but I'm not necessarily gonna
put myself in a position to where I'ma
be going back to jail you feel like I
only go to jail for guns right every
time I go to jail it's for guns so for
me not to go back to jail I can't
surround myself in certain areas where
I'ma need a gun and if I do then you
feel also like you gotta be just mindful
of the environment we're in now man our
muffins is getting killed nothing and
that's the thing for us Rolex for it's
crazy like you know Rolex we just talk
about pnb rock like yeah that was crazy
insane man like dude it at a restaurant
eating with this girl and in front of
[ __ ] is bold now because back in my
day
we was robbing [ __ ] a week our main
thing was [ __ ] don't
don't
shoot nobody because that's when your
charges get serious don't shoot nobody
that was like we didn't want to shoot
nobody never wanted to shoot nobody if
you robbing them now you getting shot
before you getting robbed you getting
shot dead then robbed yeah or the other
way you're getting robbed and still
getting shot man it's [ __ ] up these
[ __ ] crazy yeah cause like you said
like if the goal is not to shoot anybody
because that's when you you're gonna go
to prison for life people are still
robbing you and then just shooting you
just that's because that's cause look at
the world now though everybody got ski
mask huh everyone's got the [ __ ] it's
legal to write or be anywhere in any
business organization with a ski mask so
when you seeing this [ __ ] every day a
[ __ ] walk through with a ski mask on
you just look at him whatever now
[ __ ] walking in with ski masks and
this [ __ ] fitting to do something
somebody you don't even know because you
see this every day you see somebody
walking with a ski mask on every day so
you're kind of comfortable with it now
because you you see it so much yeah so
this is getting bold because [ __ ] you
can't see nobody face we gotta stop the
interview tell you about our partners at
Odd Socks well first of all let's check
out the brand new collab
look at these the bootleg capsock you
see my pink ass face on those [ __ ]
socks and nobody wants to buy those
we're gonna figure out a way to give
them away though uh but look Odd Socks
the most comfortable socks in the world
um and the best thing about Odd Socks is
they're our family man I've been rocking
with these guys for about 10 years now
and I will not wear anything else on my
feet like I swear to God I'm about to
take my shoe off I'm about to take the
look what is this
smells great too that's an odd sock
right there that's an odd sock basic you
know what I'm saying we [ __ ] with Odd
Socks you should too they got the crazy
licenses we're talking about Nickelodeon
shout out to Patrick [ __ ]
Cheez-Its Baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little Pop-Tart underwear you
know what I mean yeah these are the Odd
Socks Basics all right so if you go to
the website right now order you some
underwear order you some socks use the
promo code bootleg Kev that's one word
altogether bootleg Kev and you will save
20 off at checkout go to
oddsocksofficial.com one more time
that's oddsocksofficial.com promo code
bootleg Kev and you will save 20 off
your order of course represented by Odd
Socks and we are proud to say so all
right let's get back to the interview
crazy that now like it's like well I
mean hopefully it starts to lighten up
but yeah Peak pandemic they hit my car
for like I had left a bank and uh they
hit me for like 15 bands fresh out of
the bank they was watching you no that
no no so so we got surveillance camera
there was a girl in line at the bank
watching everybody she followed me out
got into a car with two dudes but her
whole [ __ ] face was covered up bro so
it's like of course her face was covered
up it's [ __ ] the middle of the
[ __ ] pandemic I don't know what this
[ __ ] looks like like you know what I'm
saying like you know what they broken
tail so what happened was I was at the
bank and I was I was um I was trying to
open up a bank account with uh one of my
business partners and his name was on
like that list
yeah they wouldn't give him a bank
account because he got [ __ ] up credit
so I had like 15K on me and I had like a
big blue like deposit bag and I was like
all right well you know I told the lady
at the bank I was like hey can I just
deposit this in my personal account real
quick and she's like well you gotta wait
in the line and the line at the bank
during the pandemic was insane this [ __ ]
was out the building bro so I was like
man [ __ ] that I'll just come back later
so I'm walking out I got you know
obviously whoever was in the line saw me
with a fat [ __ ] blue deposit bag
I literally drive like three blocks away
jump out of the car to run into the UPS
Store my car's parked right there
within like 30 seconds of me being in
there bust my window took my backpack
took my bread it was in the trunk oh
they bust a window pop the turn grabbed
all that yeah they good I'm sick
yeah I like that like the the only two
times I've ever felt like damn I could
kill somebody was
hey I know that feeling good Brooke
and you don't know where to look who to
get man bro I got bit so quick I went to
this clothing store in Oakland
I had just left from cool John
getting some some of that cool John Weed
yeah you feel me I bought like two
pounds off of it I had 100 pounds in the
front seat and one in the back I ran
into I went into the clothing store man
these four little [ __ ] walked past me
they're like oh what's up D-Lo dude I'm
like what's happening bro am I going to
the store I'm in there no I'm not lying
but I'm in there for probably like two
minutes some lady walking and said is
anybody in a black such and such I'm
like yeah she like your window broke I'm
like [ __ ] I'll run out there I said bro
these little [ __ ] just said what's up
to me you got the packs
no they only got one they got the one in
the front seat you can tell they Bentley
grabbed it and got up out of there you
feel me I'm like God I'm like I don't
even know who to look for I ain't never
seen these [ __ ] a day in my life yo
it's the worst because you're like you
said like there's like zero bro I was on
some real like CSI [ __ ] though man
I was trying to track them down oh my I
paid the dude for the footage of the
[ __ ] parking lot I got the
maker the car the license plate was too
fuzzy uh I bro I was so [ __ ] it was I
was like man I'm gonna find out these
[ __ ] are hell yeah I'm gonna
get my [ __ ] back I just wanted my laptop
back because I was like yo it's got
files and [ __ ] I'm like yo keep the
money [ __ ] it this money is fair okay
but give me my my computer and my
passport back that was hot bro
I was yeah that was that was rough um
all right well look man new music coming
new single coming a little single coming
a lot more other [ __ ] coming too though
a lot more at the [ __ ] are you gonna get
into the weed game I mean obviously on
the on the legal side of things
definitely you're gonna have your own
strain I'm already working on that right
now as we speak I was working on that
before I got out that's beautiful man so
I'm already working on all that we I got
the strands coming I got a lot of merch
coming I I I'm my one I'm my one right
now merch some tree some music
definitely lots of freedom in your
horizon
lots of it there it is man my guy Dilo
appreciate you pulling up bro